look Sarah in the ice she wasn't there
take my advice and return Sarah to the
great John Constantine I need your help
what your sister needs is a restoration
of their soul to her body if something
goes wrong if things go wrong that would
all be to guide to carry on with the
show
hey youtubers is Charlie the moment is
finally here we have constatine footage
for arrow next week so there's gonna be
a breakdown of that as well as the Q&A
from flash and arrow this week good
stuff first constatine on arrow what
does this mean for the future of the
character and what does this mean for
the larger DC TV universe when that Ryan
was hired to come on arrow this year it
was just the deal for this one episode
they didn't sign a multi-episode deal
but he could come back Matt Ryan is
totally happy to play the character
again he's a totally awesome dude
he's actually he's starting a play on
Broadway with Keira Knightley and he's
filming a movie soon so I don't know how
long it's gonna be before he comes back
but because they were able to make this
deal I think it means that they'll be
able to make deals like this in the
future the deal itself was only for Matt
Bryan though so none of the other
Constantine characters are gonna come on
but he might tell some jokes about his
friends from air quotes back home the
time is short so he's mostly being
brought on to bind Sara's soul back to
her body that that's like the whole deal
is that she doesn't have a soul right
now Matt Ryan was asked what's different
about this version of Constantine than
the version that he did on the NBC show
he said it's essentially the same
character same outfit but he's doing a
couple things that he did not do on the
NBC show it's a little more spectacular
like I mean if you're gonna bring a
character this big on arrow of course
they're gonna have some fun with them he
did say some specific things about the
action sequences but I'll just I'll
leave that for Wednesday just in the
interest of not spoiling things but just
in terms of the future of the
Constantine TV show I'm not expecting
that to go to CW anytime soon they
already have problems fitting all the
shows that they've bought into their
schedule right now legends of tomorrow
presents a bit of a problem for them
because their spring schedule is already
full so in order to air legends of
tomorrow they're gonna have to push one
of their other shows already so I don't
think they have room for Constantine
right now but he's a big DC character so
there's always gonna be reboots down the
road so like there at some point there
will be another Constantine TV show but
for the time being what I think that
they'll do is just try to use him in
these CW shows the next logical step
would be to use him in legends of
tomorrow in like a big blockbuster
episode that's like the big summer
disaster movie version of these DC TV
shows they're doing fewer episodes so
they're spending a little bit more money
on each one so if they were to bring
Constantine on he
could do crazier and crazier stuff than
he could ever do on a smaller budget but
if you're still confused about what's
going on there is no Konstantine TV show
in the works at CW like there there's no
talks going on about that and this is
just a one-off deal for now but the
writers will bring anyone on that DC
will let them bring on look people ask
them can you bring Batman on the show
they're like we would love to bring
Batman on if Warner Brothers in DC would
let us so yeah you'll definitely see
Constantine on Flash narrow after this
week but maybe not till next season so
on a q-and-a territory just careful for
spoilers from flash and arrow this past
week if you haven't seen the episodes
yet and they're actually there weren't
that many questions from the flash
mostly just people wanting to see King
shark fight other big CG villains from
DC like here we go Christiaan Barnard
asks imagine king shark vs. Grodd king
shark hands-down the biggest WTF in my
book this season is so exciting yeah
king shark versus drop would be amazing
and they are bringing Grodd on pretty
soon but I don't I don't really know
what their budget allows for in terms of
CG fights if you remember last season
whatever garage came on in the flash
bottom there were portions where it was
Grant Gustin interacting with a
green-screen device and then there were
fully CG scenes where it was a grant
gustin fighting Grodd at SuperSpeed that
that's when they go full CG flash I
always feel like their level of
special-effects is good enough so that
if you don't use it too much and you
don't do faces and clothes up it looks
perfect it's totally good next question
fab Robin asks I thought Francine's son
was Daniel West the new 52 zoom yeah
the flash TV show tends to blend a lot
of different runs of the comics the
wally west of earth one like the eye
irises brother that she was talking
about in the episode will be wally west
he will become kid flash at a certain
point and i remember even before the new
52 there are a couple different
iterations of wally west you have the
first version who became kid flash he
wore like the red costume that looked
just like Barry Allen's then he started
wearing the yellow costume then after
crisis on Infinite Earths he started
wearing the red costume again after he
took the mantle from Barry Allen became
like full-blown flash so because they're
going with the character that looks like
the new 52 version of Wally West the the
african-american Wally West I have no
idea what his costume might look like at
a certain point no idea when he's going
to get flash powers but he will be kid
flash first
now that says nothing about what's going
on on earth - I'm just talking about
earth one wally west
next question bradley asks will Ronnie
be back yeah he will definitely be back
robbie amell will come back on the show
but we don't know what form that's gonna
take the producer said flat out that our
version of Ronnie died whenever they
were closing the wormhole so when we see
Robbie Amell again it'll either be a
flashback or it'll be earth to Ronnie on
arrow questions here we go Wilfred asks
could you talk about how much Oliver the
CW universe could look like
Oliver of the comics is there any chance
of him becoming the comical long-haired
with the goatee husband of Black Canary
Oliver we all know from the comics well
I I don't know how close he'll get to
Oliver of the classic comics they always
changed iterations whenever they reboot
the comics so post convergence I haven't
been reading Green Arrow so I don't know
how they changed the character again he
is sporting more facial hair right now
but I don't know if he'll go full Oliver
beard and I don't think that his actual
hair like on the on top of his head will
ever get any longer than it is right now
but physical appearance any side his
actual character is getting a little bit
more laid back a little bit more used to
the team a little bit more humorous a
little bit closer to his Justice League
persona now in terms of his relationship
with Black Canary I I don't see his
relationship with Laurel changing
anytime soon on the show one of the
problems with having like two two
characters on a team have sex with each
other is that it can pull the show
towards melodrama
when it's really meant to be more of a
crime drama next question Martin asks
how is it possible that Oliver never
wins fights anymore I think it's because
he's too trusting people catch him off
guard like if he's fully prepared no
like there's no way you're gonna beat
him but I think a lot of people were
upset with the last episode with the
quickness with which lady cop was able
to dispatch him one of the problems with
filming stuff like that is that they
might have written it a certain way on
the page to make it look like she got
the upper hand on Oliver and in a dirty
way and when they film it that doesn't
really come across so just think of her
is fighting dirty catching all of her
off-guard and she did jam that knife
into his spine so he was completely
immobilized like no no matter how strong
he was he wouldn't be able to do
anything that moment really wasn't about
the fight at all it was really just
getting her character to jump over that
moral hurdle to realize okay I'm a human
being
I'm not a terrible person I'll turn
myself in so that's what they were going
for but it just it may not have come
across the way it was filmed thank you
everyone that submitted questions on the
videos this week though and if you do
want me to use your question in a Q&A be
sure to use Jeopardy rules and and
phrase your comment in the form of a
question
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner the reverse flash ring
astrophysics 43 just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info so what's
happening next is is there's Gotham and
Supergirl on Monday I'm probably gonna
post my Gotham video first and if you
didn't see the last Supergirl video I
post I posted like a trailer video for
episode 2 I said that I'm probably gonna
be doing Supergirl videos on Thursdays
so they'll be a little bit different
from my typical top five WTF videos that
I do for episodes but just stay tuned
for the next Supergirl video I post
it'll completely explain everything but
if you're confused about when videos are
posting just follow me on Twitter and
Facebook that's usually where I post
updates oh and just a heads up normally
Game of Thrones will be posting on
Sundays
I'm just moving that to Monday just
because everything's been backed up with
me moving to a new apartment this week
so no worries
still Game of Thrones coming so there is
new Walking Dead tonight while you guys
wait for that and everything else to
post you can click here for my flash
episode 5 trailer bunch of zoom a bunch
of dr. light and you can click here for
that Supergirl trailer video I talked
about thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight